shopping sucks all I wanted to do was
buy a new t-shirt but this sales
associate she had other plans for me
hi welcome to insight retail store names
here how can I help you today I was
looking for a new t-shirt today we have
know what t-shirts a long sleeve shirt
with the sleeves cut off a t-shirt do
you have and he's beautiful
hundred percent high fabulous on
anybody's head okay I'm sure the shirts
are very lovely but I want a t-shirt but
even better you feel the more credit
cogs let's say you believe we percent
off your entire purchase with a 50% off
the last Tuesday of every month okay
thank you I don't need a credit card I'm
just gonna go see if I can find a shirt
on my own okay things especially hard be
careful date they're simply gonna
missing here okay I already know I
wanted to shirts I want a long sleeve
shirt with no sleeves that's what I want
you're making me very emotional right
now and I can't take it but you know
what I will take take your hunters that
battery-operated pigs and I am leaving
[Music]
music